what is up everybody welcome back to the
cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson and
here's the deal I've always loved DC DC
has some of my favorite characters in
fact Batman is my all-time favorite
character right alongside of Thor and DC
is about to make a huge comeback and I
think we're about to live in a world not
where DC and Marvel compete and are
compared to each other but a world where
we get great content from both yes the
past has been rough for DC and yes phase
four wasn't so great to a lot of fans in
the MCU but Phase 5 and 6 should be
great and DC has a lot planned for their
future but most importantly DC seems to
have figured out a road map and it's
super super awesome so let's talk about
DC's exciting future also if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe
we're going to be talking a lot about DC
coming up and of course Marvel as well
and if you're interested in the Marvel
Legends giveaway just subscribe to the
channel and comment down below to be
entered now one thing that we have to be
honest about is that this despite
whether you enjoyed phase 4 or you
didn't like some movies in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe or you don't like any
of them at all you have to admit that
their Cinematic Universe and the
connectivity that it provided through
all of their films was executed very
very well in fact they pretty much set
the bar for it and this is something
that DC unfortunately has had problems
with connectivity and continuity but I
am happy to say that that is coming to
an end and the DCU officially titled the
DC Universe DCU is about to be a
connected Cinematic Universe and while
DC isn't exactly copying Marvel we are
going to see two universes start to have
the same format as DC is now also going
to have phases and the overall
connectivity of the universe is going to
be so much better than it ever was
before before we never really knew much
about what their plan was and what was
connecting or not connecting but now
it's all about to be made very very
clear and that's thanks to some big
changes that DC has r already made
starting with the biggest change or I
should say biggest two changes and that
is of course the iconic James Gunn and
Peter saffron are now co-partners that
officially have the helm in leading the
projects when it comes to DC Studios
they're in charge so needless to say
Walter Hamada is no longer in that
position and with the company but James
Gunn and Peter saffron have already done
so much for in 2dc with the short amount
of time that they've held this position
now something that I do need to address
first is that yesterday we did get some
pretty shocking news the news came last
night that Warner Brothers was scrapping
Wonder Woman 3 and Man of Steel 2.
however recent reports have come out
stating that James Gunn simply didn't
like the vision that they had for Wonder
Woman in Wonder Woman 3 and he didn't
think it was going to be that good
apparently he was supposed to be handed
an entire script for Wonder Woman 3 but
was only handed a few pieces of paper
that didn't really do any justice to the
character so he kind of decided to scrap
it but he does have plans for Wonder
Woman and the future of the DCU I'm
assuming it's a similar thing for Henry
Cavill Superman considering the fact
that he just got back to the DCU and it
was a pretty big deal to get him back
I'm assuming they're not just going to
get rid of him altogether I'm assuming
what was happening is that Man of Steel
2 simply wasn't coming together the way
that the DCU was going to be rebooted
and it didn't simply work with their
plans that does not mean Henry Cavill
Superman is gone they are simply doing
what is best to fit these characters and
proper stories in the DCU so this is
actually a good thing because these
decisions are coming from James Gunn and
Peter Safran so I know a lot of people
were panicking about these decisions but
I think they are good decisions James
Gunn has definitely been talked about a
lot in the news recently especially with
him being the producer of the Guardians
of the Galaxy Trilogy and the director
as well and most recently the awesome
Christmas special with the guardians but
of course him also giving us the suicide
squad for DC and The Peacemaker series
both of which were really awesome
however some fans are upset why he is
still a huge face for Marvel however he
has a great response to those remarks if
you know anything about James Gunn you
know that he is active on Twitter and he
calls people out a lot and he responds a
lot he basically wants to always have
the record set straight here was his
response to people telling him that he's
still at Marvel when he's now in charge
of DC he said in a tweet as was made
clear in all press until May I am both
DC and Marvel I've dedicated the
majority of the past 10 years of my life
to the Guardians Trilogy and I'm not
abandoning them or the thousands of
people who worked on them at the 11th
Hour the world won't end if you love
both and he's entirely right and like
I've mentioned he's already done a lot
for DC so James Gunn will still be a
part of Marvel until May but since he is
such a legend with what he's done with
the Guardians of the Galaxy he will
always be a part of Marvel at heart and
let's not downplay Peter South friend
because he has produced Big projects as
well like Shazam and The Suicide Squad
the second one that is and even more in
the horror side like Annabelle and
here's what's really cool these two
James and Peter will continue to help DC
produce DC content rather than just
overseeing everything they're going to
be Hands-On involved we also have to
give some credit to Dwayne Johnson AKA
Black Adam or the rock for helping DC
out at a pretty big time he brought us
Black Adam an action-packed film and
showed us that DCU film projects will
now be released in phases much like
Marvel does which is a great thing but
what's really awesome of course is that
he brought back Henry Cavill so you can
see big changes being made at DC but how
exactly is it going to be so different
than it was before well for one it is
now in the hands of true fans and the
people who are surrounding them like the
Rock and Henry Cavill who really want to
see this universe Excel people who have
proven track records of making great
superhero films and shows basically we
have EX experience and passion now
something that I feel DC kind of lacked
before in regards to the people and the
executives behind making the movie
decisions that is and another huge thing
is that everything is going to be a lot
more clear for the universe and how it's
connected in fact right now James Gunn
and Peter Safran are working on what
they call a Bible for DC they are almost
finished with it as well and this is
basically something that's going to help
guide us through every part of DC and
show how it's either all connected or
not this includes the films TV shows
animated series and games which is
another big announcement by James Gunn
that is going to very much impact the DC
Universe in a great way James Gunn
tweeted that everything that DC is going
to put out now is going to be tied to
the DCU that means the films and TV
shows an animated series will all tie
into the DC Universe basically like how
Marvel does it with the MCU and how they
are fluent across the board with their
continuity now James Gunn and Peter
saffron will will make things very
easier and more exciting to follow
throughout all the Realms of DC he even
says that some video games are going to
be tied to the DCU as well which is
really awesome however he did respond to
another tweet about the video games
being connected to the DCU and his
remark is that not all will be tied to
it so some video games and this makes
sense because sometimes it's okay to do
one-offs or other things to Branch out
but you could only Branch out so far
that is if you are going to have a truly
connected Universe a perfect example of
branching out is Robert Pattinson's the
Batman which is not connected to the DCU
it's a one-off project nonetheless it
was an amazing movie but the bottom line
is we are going to have more continuity
and more connections on the DC Universe
and to take this even further it does
look like they are going to kind of
clean up some things that they've
already done before because they're not
going to completely erase everything
that has happened before some stuff will
still connect however we are going to be
starting in Phase One black Adam
technically was the first project of
DC's phase one but they are still going
to connect some things of the past but
they're gonna have to clean it up a bit
and David zasloff has said that there's
not going to be four Batmans so they're
cleaning it up a bit just to make it
less confusing which is great but also
sad because I would have loved to have
seen four Batmans on screen at the same
time but I think it's the right choice
one final thing that is worth noting is
that channy Dungey talked about closing
a deal with Amazon to get animated
series for DC on Amazon Prime video that
would be another win for DC so they
definitely seem to have everything in
place to make the DCU fantastic and most
importantly they have the right people
in charge now who have passion and
experience in making good superhero
movies even great superhero movies so
the future is bright for DC hopefully
they can make a pretty big comeback and
it looks like they are and I'm
definitely here for it I'm ready for it
I love DC I love Marvel you can love
both it's okay and I'm ready for both of
them to be amazing but hey let me know
your thoughts about this in the comments
down below what do you think about DC
are they going to make a comeback or not
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe for more DC and Marvel news
for live updates you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof